simply 3x squared minus 8x plus 7 plus 2x to the third minus x squared plus eight x minus 3
so when we simplify this we're essentially going to add up like terms
and just as a reminder we can only add or subtract like terms or simplify like terms
and just a reminder and what I mean by that if I had an x squared to an x squared
these are like terms they're both x terms raised to the same power
the same degree
so if I have one x squared and another x squared well then I have 2x squared - this is 2x squared
If I have an x to the third - let's say I have 3x to thirds plus another 4x to the thirds
Well that means I have 7x to the thirds - 7x to the thirds
I can't take an x squared and add it to an x to the third I cannot simplify this in any way, so this you cannot simplify
cannot simply - these are not like terms just because they both have Xs
The Xs are not to - they are not to the same degree
With that in mind let's look at the Xs to the same degree
Let's start with the highest degree
So the highest degree or the highest exponent on an x here - is actually this x to the third here
but it looks like the only one it's the only place where we're raising x to the third power
so that can't be merged or added or subtracted to anything else
so let's just write that down.
so we have 2x to the third
and let's look at the x squared terms. We have 3x squared over there
and we have a minus or we can view as a negative x squared over there
so if we want to simplify we can add these two terms - we can add- so let me just write it down
we can add 3x squared to negative x squared
so I'm just rearranging it really right now
I'm putting the like terms next to each other so it'll be easy to simplify
now let's just worry about the x to the first terms or just the x terms
you have a negative 8x term right over here
so let me write it over here
negative 8x and then you have a positive 8x term right over here, so let me write that down
so positive 8x
and then finally let's look at the constant terms
you can view those as times x to the zeroth power
and the constant terms are - you have a positive 7 over here - so plus 7
and then you have a negative 3 over here
you have a negative 3
so all I'll I've done is I've really just used the communative property of addition
to just change the order - or addition and subtraction - to change the order in which I'm doing this
I've just rearranged the things so the like terms are next to each other
but now we can simplify
so we have 2x to the third - nothing to simplify that with
but then if we subtract - if we have - let me do that in the same blue color
if we have 3x squared and from that we're taking away an x squared
well, we're only gonna have 2x squared left
so that's gonna be plus 2x squared
and then over here if we have negative 8 Xs
and then we add 8 Xs to it or you can actually swap these around
you could view it as you are subtracting 8 x from positive 8x
we'll those are just going to cancel out
so it's just going to be zero - I could just write plus zero here, but that'd just be redundant it wouldn't change the value
and then finally I have a plus 7 minus 3 well that is just clearly
7 minus 3 is 4 so I have plus 4
And we're done! We've simplified it!
2x to the third plus 2 x squared plus 4